on the other hand this now-familiar
pairing begs the question are
transcultural judgments really possible
can we honestly claim to be able to
apprehend objects of a different culture
on its own terms what critical framework
is to be used if we are to make a
qualitative assessment this is not just
an academic exercise in a museum such
works may very well be considered for
purchase and large sums of money out of
a pool common to buying in all fields
may well be required are the criteria we
use necessarily relative is there really
no universal standard for me it remains
a conundrum for many others I know this
is actually a non-issue artists of all
cultures it is argued grapple with like
challenges and works of art should be
judged as mentioned a couple of times
before on their own terms which means
what exactly that we have the Western
tradition make allowances to all remote
or alien cultures mysterious subjects
strange forms perhaps so but if we are
decision-makers we are then compelled to
rely blindly almost on the expertise of
a great many specialists and in the end
it seems that best of kind has replaced
the notion of simply the best whenever
and wherever not replacing but creating
a new form of parochialism for my part I
continue to hold that we can play some
trust in our own response to the art of
any culture and this is because I
believe in the innate power of great
works of art to reach us on some level
on their capability to assert
their moral authority their compelling
message and if a work of art touches us
in some way I believe it is because it
is successful no matter when made or
where or by whom successful because it
conveys strongly unmistakably even that
the artists intention even if only
imputed is in fact achieved in short
that the artifact works and when it does
to me that is something palpable